-It is great to see you, buddy.
-Thank you for having me. Yeah.
-Clearly, they know who you are.
-Yeah. Hi.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome to the show.
I'm a fan, as well, by the way.
-Hey...
-I heard this backstage, but
this is your talk-show debut?
-It's my first-ever
talk show, yeah.
-I appreciate it, buddy.
Thank you.
-It's so nice to be here,
because I very nearly
didn't make it.
-What? What do you mean?
-I was held up
at immigration yesterday.
-[ Gasps ] Oh, gosh.
-Ever been secondary?
Ever been secondary? Anyone?
-No.
-No? Oh, it's not so fun.
I was taken into -- I guess
what you could call it --
It was more of a dungeon.
And I was asked to wait there
for about 20 minutes.
And then I was summoned to this
desk, where someone asked me,
"What are you doing
in the United States, sir?"
I said, "Well, I'm actually here
to meet Jimmy Fallon
on 'The Tonight Show.'"
-Yeah.
-And he didn't believe me.
And one of his colleagues looked
over at me, looked to him, said,
"Leave Eddie alone."
And then...
♪♪
And then he said, "Who are you?
I don't know."
He's like, "It's Eddie from
'Stranger Things.'"
He's like,
"You're Eddie Munson?"
And I was like, "Kind of."
He was like,
"Do you come back next season?"
And I said, "Um, I don't know."
And he was like, "You better,"
gave me the passport.
-And there you go.
That's the power of
Eddie Munson.
-Crazy. Crazy, crazy.
But I'm very glad
that you let me come,
because I brought
you a present, Jimmy.
-You don't have to bring me --
-Well, no, no, no.
But I wanted to.
-What?
-We're missing a member.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Hey.
-No way.
-Yeah, no, no, no, no, no.
-Really?
-We'd be honored.
-I am honored.
I am part of the Hellfire Club?
-Come on.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dude...
Come on. I am honored.
I will wear this. I cannot wait.
Thank you so much
for bringing me this gift.
-No, it's our pleasure.
-I'll wear this
through immigration.
It'll be fantastic.
It's probably been a
crazy couple months for you,
I can imagine, huh?
-It's been pretty weird, yeah.
It's been amazing, though.
I went to Brazil.
I've never been there before.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Aah. You've been.
-Yeah.
People are passionate
about your character.
People love you. You crushed it.
-Oh, bless you.
-You're so good.
But, I mean,
what are people connecting with
with your character?
-I don't know. I think --
I went to Comic-Con recently,
and it was so moving
to see how much people
have identified with him.
And I think it's probably
the fact that he's an outsider,
a little bit kind of
on the fringes of society.
And, yeah, I mean, it's just
such -- It's so moving to see
how much he means to people.
-I know Jack Black gave
you a shout-out the other night.
-I know.
-I love that dude.
-He's the best.
-He's the greatest dude.
-I've, you know, worshiped that
guy since "School of Rock."
And, yeah,
that was pretty crazy.
-But, also, I mean, it's great
to even just hear you talk,
because I didn't even know
that you're --
that you're not American.
But you're -- Sorry.
They should've told you that
at immigration.
Yeah, yeah. That's the
first thing they tell you.
Yeah, you're not --
But you played it so well.
And this was my favorite scene,
I would say.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're doing "Master of Puppets"
by Metallica,
and it was just
the greatest thing.
Do you know that song
is nearly 40 years old,
and because of you,
it became the number-1 song
in the country.
-Yeah.
I get no royalties, though.
-Yeah. Ah, you got to work
on that one, yeah.
-Yeah, no, it's awesome.
-Metallica -- they're, like,
the most legendary band
of all time, and you go, like --
Do you get nervous going like,
"I'm going to do
'Master of Puppets'"?
-It was kind of nerve-racking,
but it was a weird point
in the pandemic
where no one had seen
any live music for ages.
And it was me and Gaten.
You've had Gaten on.
-Yeah.
-Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. He's the best.
And it was so fun.
I was nervous, but it was
kind of like a rock concert,
and I got to feel like
a rock star for one night,
and that was pretty great.
-Yeah, one night -- that's all
you need.
-That's all I need.
-But it's legendary.
It's now legendary.
And what you did,
even what you did for Metallica
too, even, like,
you weren't connected.
It was like you'd made
that song number 1.
I go, "Oh, my gosh.
They must have freaked out."
You've created memes, GIFs,
everything that you can think of
on the Internet.
There's this thing that
I was looking at on TikTok.
It's from @Schmoyoho.
Schmoyoho.
-Schmoyoho.
-He made a remix of using your
line, "Chrissy, wake up," and --
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's the funniest thing.
I don't know if you've seen it.
Let's just show the video.
This is --
I think it's your voice
or as they revoiced it and made
it into, like, a song.
Because you're
like, "Chrissy, wake up,"
and she's about to get
snapped into pieces.
But, anyways, check this out.
♪ Chrissy, wake up ♪
-Yeah.
-Did you see that?
-I think I probably got about
15 minutes today
where that wasn't
flying around in my head.
So it's nice to have it back.
Yeah, I think it's so funny.
Well done, whoever did that.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
People also --
they love your relationship
in the show with Dustin,
with Gaten,
who we love on the show.
-Romantic boy.
-Yeah.
He's a special dude, right?
He's just a talented kid.
-You've had him on here.
-He told me -- he goes,
"You have to meet --"
He goes like,
"You got to meet Joe."
-Oh, did he?
-Yeah.
So did Joe.
Joe Keery said the same thing.
-Have you had him on here?
-Yes.
-Sorry.
-They both love you
and they're like,
"Oh, wait till --
You're gonna love this guy."
They had
the greatest time with you.
-I had the best time with them.
I think I was quite nervous
about this dynamic,
because, I mean, yeah, I think
you guys have seen the show.
Gaten and Joe's character,
their dynamic is something
that people really, really like.
And I was very conscious,
like, stepping into it
and being Gaten's side Joe
and not really
wanting to step --
-Side Joe.
-Yeah, no, his Joe on the side.
And kind of not wanting to step
on anyone's toes,
but actually became, like,
the thing that --
one of the things that
I most enjoyed about it,
because me and Joe
would just compare little
Gaten anecdotes constantly.
-But, I mean,
your American accent,
as I said earlier,
it's great in the show.
I've heard you do --
I heard that you do
a bunch of different accents.
-I do some bad accents.
-Yeah.
Well, I was wondering, tonight,
if you can, if we can hear
one of Eddie's monologues.
We have it
written on cue cards there.
But you do it using
different accents.
So, do Eddie Munson
if he was from
different parts of the world.
And for those --
I just want to show the wig,
because it's just so worth it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, this is --
I love my T-shirt.
Alright, this is Joseph Quinn
performing a scene from
"Stranger Things"
with different accents.
Whenever you're ready.
-Whenever I'm ready.
-Yes.
-Okay. Is it to this?
-Yeah, this one. Yep.
-To this guy?
-Yep.
-Okay. First one.
-Scottish.
[ Scottish accent ]
We are the freaks.
[ Normal voice ]
Why's he got a lisp?
-He doesn't have a lisp.
-Wait.
-He's got a lisp.
-No.
-Why not?
-Okay.
-[ Scottish accent ]
We are the freaks,
because we like to play
a fantasy game.
[ Ding ]
-That's a double.
Double points for that.
Alright.
-Okay. Liverpool. Okay.
-Liverpool.
[ Liverpudlian accent ] Boy...
Boy, as long as you're into band
or science or parties...
[ Ding ]
-That's pretty good.
-[ Normal voice ]
My mom's from Liverpool,
and she sounds exactly
like that.
Australian.
[ Australian accent ]
Oh, a bloody game where you toss
bloody balls
into bloody baskets.
[ Ding ]
-Yes. Very good.
Oh, New York.
-New York.
[ New York accent ]
New York. Oh!
It's forced conformity. Oh!
[ Ding ]
Uh...Welsh.
[ Welsh accent ]
That's what's killin' the kids.
That's the real monster.
-That's how you do it
right there!
The real monster.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Joseph Quinn in
"Stranger Things."
Take a look at this. Yeah!
-Hear me now.
There will be
no more retreating...
from "Eddie the Banished."
-Hey, you're really ready
for bat-tle.
[ Laughs ]
Do you get it?
Bat-tle.
B-A-T.
No? Alright.
I thought I had some good ones.
-Aah!
-What are you doing?
Aah!
No wedgies! No wedgies!
-Never change, Dustin Henderson.
Promise me?
-I wasn't planning on it.
-Good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on.
Dude, please come back.
Please come back.
Joseph Quinn, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Season 4 of "Stranger Things"
is streaming now on Netflix.
We'll be right back with
a performance from Toro y Moi.
Stick around, everybody.